after months of delay and contradictory
messages from the ministry of health
iraq's covet 19 vaccination campaign has
begun
we've now received 336 000 vaccines and
they've been distributed according to
plan to health clinics across
iraq the priority are health workers
security forces the elderly and people
with immunity disorders
that prioritization plan has yet to be
implemented
the government first asked people to
register online but because of limited
uptake
it then opened the doors to everyone
including young people like
faisal there isn't enough encouragement
from the government to take the vaccine
so i don't have the priority to take the
vaccine but i know
if i don't come and take it maybe it
would get expired and nobody's going to
take it
indeed this batch of vaccines expires at
the end of may
authorities race against time to
mobilize a reluctant public
that distrusts both the government and
science
sixty-five-year-old abdelrahman should
be a priority candidate
he suffers from hypertension diabetes
and had one of his kidneys removed
but he has no intention of getting the
vaccine
people are scared especially the elderly
vaccines contain cortisol
which can stop the lungs so if you ask
the elderly about taking the vaccine
their answer will be no iraq's
government is facing a dual
challenge when it comes to inoculating
the population
on the one hand it must convince people
to get the vaccine
and at the same time it's struggling to
secure doses
from global suppliers the astrazeneca
inoculations
iraq has received are part of 16 million
doses it has been allocated under kovacs
the global vaccine alliance to ensure
equitable distribution of vaccines
but the world health organization's top
official in iraq
says delivering on those commitments has
been a challenge
as producing countries prioritize their
own needs
the kovacs facility have have had some
delays
because the manufacturers did not
produce as much
vaccines to honor the
estimated doses to be distributed
while those vaccines are pending
delivery new covet 19 cases are hovering
above 5000 daily
as the country experiences its highest
levels of infection
since the onset of the pandemic simona
14 al jazeera
baghdad